you're no longer a big user of email
that's true can you tell me about your
attitude to email them and is it as
something other people should consider
is this disgusting well as I said on the
web I'm not I'm a special case I'm not
my role in life is not to be on top of
things as much as to be on the bottom of
things it's best often for me to be a
bit of a hermit and and and have time
for things that require long attention
span and no interruptions email is name
of the game is interruption on the other
hand I do impose on other people and ask
them random questions but starting about
1990 I realized that I had done I
decided to use the email in 1975 and
fifteen years of it was a kind of a
lifetime's worth as far as I could see
because I had become true does a random
Oracle people all over would just ask me
random questions and I would dutifully
reply not only that but I as an author I
also don't want to just - something off
but I read it off make sure that my
sentences are well constructed and
spelled correctly and so on so it took a
long time and it turned out that I was
spending you know I would start out with
an idea of what I could do that day and
then four hours later I say okay now let
me just let me try to go forward after
after processing email on the other hand
I sent a question to a guy I mean I had
my secretary send a question to a guy
last week and I'm disturbed that he
hasn't replied yet that's not so I'm not
being fair I'm not opposing on other
people and not letting them impose on me
the people bring it up with you the main
problem is that they that they try to go
through my wife and then bother her up
and so so I have to
just try to stop that as soon as I can
it was an indescribably great experience
it really was because there were so many
people there who were so good and the
environment was totally open and
supportive if you had a problem it was
like the quarters of building
everybody's office door was open you
could say I have a problem to anybody
and they would try and help you they
would drop whatever they were doing